This. Oh,
bags on bags on bags on bags.
I ordered the Love Duke or whatever travel bag.
I'm very excited. Okay.
Packaged amazingly. Definitely save some life.
Oh, wow.
It really is safely package.
Hold up.
Oh, I love it.
Let's see what it's like on.
Oh, this is fucking perfect.
Oh my god, I love it.
Okay. It's got mad space.
I love that you can cinch it.
Okay, it's got this for the suitcase.
Oh, nice quick shit.
You just get to something,
but it's not here, so it's safe.
Like this sturdy ass handle.
Oh, a pocket here.
Oh, and it's nice inside.
It's like soft. A bag here
in case you gotta hold it this way.
Okay. I love this thing.
Pocket with pockets. Pockets on pockets, bitches.
Okay, this is why I got it.
Cause it opens up like a suitcase,
so I can still fill it like a suitcase.
This one's waterproof. I love that.
This one, mesh one for socks and undies so you don't lose it.
Got this thing so your clothes don't go everywhere.
This is exactly what I wanted,
these things with this guy.
Oh, this is for shoes.
This is very nice.
And then this. Oh, okay.
It's a 50 liter. And I was getting nervous
because I saw everybody else gets the 40 liter.
But I wanted to have extra space because I could always sit.
That's why I wanted these cinching things too,
because I was Like, well,
I'd rather have the 50 liter
that I could cinch it down and just use it as, like,
a carry on. This is all I'm gonna bring.
I'm like little weekend trips with my man.
Cause I'm not motherfucking married to no piece of shit no more.
She a free bitch. She a free bitch.
Going on trips. Going on trips.